hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to one late-night deadlines
so I'm an employee late at night trying
to get something done for some project
okay hello
who the hell are you Oh what the hell oh
is that me okay then why am I here late
at night
why why why the music kick up oh I
didn't call that elevator what are you
doing
this is my desk WTF
last night I was what the [ __ ] is that
attachment huh that X Mike repo factor
that's the first decent thing I've seen
I wanna like this game I don't want to
say bad things about it right away but
goddamn peel the face skip to my Lou
skip to my Lou da dippity-do gibberish
ooh bava bava do get your ass going
where's the coffee
where's the coffee where's it this is
what happens when I don't have my coffee
I just get a little angry Carly okay
alright
okay